in fact the question of genin possession
has been a contested issue among Islamic
scholars as an example of a non-septic
the famous 14th Century theologian and
hanbali jurist iban Tamia often seen as
a founding figure of salafism wrote that
quote the existence of the Jin is an
established fact according to the book
the Sunnah and the agreement of the
early Scholars on the other hand there
are other major historical Islamic
scholars that have denied its reality
such as fadin arazzi the literalist Ian
haam and maybe even Al
gazali Ian haam calls it Superstition
and says that quote such things are not
possible in other words people don't
fall for it except to the weak minds of
the elderly that he the devil can speak
using someone's tongue is sinity and
clear
insanity but regardless we can be sure
that it is and has been a very common
opinion that Jin possessions do indeed
happen